[Music]
I'm David Albert I'm a professor of
philosophy at Columbia University and my
research is mostly concerned with issues
of the foundations of physics
I think III think that philosophy of
science is at its best and at its most
exciting at historical moments when it's
not so easy to distinguish between the
activities of certain kinds of
theoretical physicists and the
philosophers philosophy of science I
think or at least well let me back up a
bit there is there's philosophy of
science can be divided roughly into two
different kinds of activities one is one
is an activity of raising and
investigating general philosophical
questions about what science is about
whether the claims of science to have
some kind of privileged epistemic access
to the world can be justified attempts
to systematize how science reasons
attempts to raise questions about
whether we should trust the conclusions
of science so on and so forth these are
very broad very traditionally
philosophical kinds of issues there's
another branch of philosophy of science
that takes up questions that arise
within particular scientific theories
the theory of evolution the theory of
relativity quantum mechanics so on and
so forth and actually gets its hands
dirty in the details of the structure of
these scientific theories in order to
try to help with problems that are often
essentially scientific problems but
we're but but whose solution calls for
an unusual degree of sensitivity to
philosophical questions it's the second
kind of work that that my own work has
mostly been and it's the second kind of
work that one refers to when one refers
to the foundations of physics there are
problems about the logical structure of
physics about the foundational
assumptions that physics makes whether
these problem
properly belong to physics or they
properly belong to philosophy when the
field is healthy isn't much of an issue
in my own case my PhD was in theoretical
physics I was a professor in physics
departments before being a professor in
philosophy departments when I write a
paper now my rule is that that if at the
end it has more than two equations in it
I send it to a physics journal and if it
has less than two I send it to a
philosophy journal and there's not much
more of a distinction than that when I
attend conferences where people are
discussing the kinds of questions that
I'm interested in about half of the
people speaking at these conferences are
employed in physics departments and half
are employed in philosophy departments
and it's not particularly easy to tell
by listening to their talks
what sort of department they're employed
in so philosophy of science like I say
when it's healthy is a matter of
focusing with a certain level of
philosophical sensitivity and
sophistication on questions at the
foundations of physics
there's a there's a glass of water on
the table beside me someone asks how do
I know that there's a glass of water on
the table beside me and the answer that
the kind of answer that the whole
structure of Western scientific
knowledge is very deeply committed to is
something like this there's light in the
room some of the light bounces off the
glass some of the light that bounces off
the glass enters my retina that causes
certain electrical excitations in my
retina that in turn causes certain
electrical excitations in my optic nerve
that causes various chemical and
electrical changes deeper in my brain
and after some finite number of such
steps my brain is in the state that
corresponds to having the impression
that there's a glass of water sitting on
the table and needless to say it's
crucial to this story that every one of
the steps I just described occurs in
full accord with whatever the
fundamental laws of physics happen to be
good it was noticed about 80 years ago
that if one supposes that the
fundamental laws of the world are
quantum mechanics
if one supposes of the fundamental
physical laws of the world are the ones
that we get in quantum mechanics
textbooks this story that I just told
about how I know there's a glass of
water on the table radically falls apart
and and it can't fall apart we can't
imagine how else to begin to tell the
story of how I know there's a glass of
water on the table so there's a problem
there's some kind of problem at the
foundations of quantum mechanics this
problem has come to be called for
reasons that are obvious given what I've
just said the measurement problem in
quantum mechanics or the observation
problem and there has been a project
under way ever since then to imagine how
to fiddle around with the fundamental
laws of quantum mechanics in such a way
as to hang on to all of the very good
predictions that the theory makes
but so as to make it possible to tell
the story of how I know that there's
this glass on the table at the same time
now this is at the end of the day a
scientific project the fact that this
story collapses indicates that something
must be amiss with the fundamental laws
of the theory and what needs to be done
in order to correct this is an
essentially scientific job of writing
down new laws that are going to be
compatible with all of the good
predictions that quantum mechanics makes
and with the possibility of telling the
story that I just described on the other
hand the problems that we run into are
peculiarly philosophical sorts of
problems what is going to count as a
solution to this problem what is it what
what is what's the minimum that we need
in order in order to be able to tell a
story like this these are questions
questions of epistemology questions of
our the relationship of our beliefs to
the external world and so on and so
forth that philosophers have been
dealing with for a long time so
philosophers can be or people with
philosophical training or philosophical
sensitivity can be helpful here in
trying to frame very precisely what the
problem is what would count as an
adequate solution to the problem so on
and so forth that's a good example and
an example which has been very very
active over the past 25 years or so of
of a problem that comes up at what used
to be thought of as the boundary between
between physical investigation and
philosophical investigation
quantum mechanics allows physical
systems and the easiest systems in which
to observe phenomena like this are very
tiny systems like subatomic particles
electrons or neutrons or protons quantum
mechanics
apparently allows for the existence of
physical conditions of material objects
like electrons in which questions about
where the electron is located in space
seem to fail to make sense let me let me
back up a little bit and explain this a
little more slowly there are experiments
we can do where an electron passes
through a certain apparatus ease is fed
into one end of an apparatus comes out
the other side of the apparatus and the
apparatus has several roots inside of it
which the electron could potentially
have taken from the input to the output
and there are experiments we can do with
pieces of apparatus like this which
taken together make a compelling case
but although the electron went from here
to there
it didn't go by root a it also didn't go
by root B and it didn't go in any in any
intelligible sense by both roots that is
it didn't split in half with 1/2 taking
one root and 1/2 taking the other root
and it also didn't take neither root ok
and what's puzzling about that is that
that would seem to be all the logical
possibilities that there are these
experiments these experiments you know
are now very routine experiments to do
in physics laboratories we've been good
at doing experiments like this for
something on the order of 70 years now
we're very good at doing them now the
results are very very compelling and
after enormous soul-searching and
puzzlement
confusion and so on and so forth the
sort of standard consensus understanding
that evolved in physics of situations
like this is that electrons could
apparently be in situations where asking
a question of the form which route did
the electron take was something like
asking a question of the form what is
the marital status of the number-5 or or
or what are the political affiliations
of this tuna sandwich or something like
that these are questions that
philosophers often refer to as category
mistakes okay the very raising of a
question about the political
affiliations of a tuna sandwich or the
marital status of the number-5 indicates
that there's something basic that you're
misunderstanding of what it is that
you're asking a question about and the
the strikingly strange thing about
quantum mechanics and indeed it seems to
me a case could be made that this is the
strangest and most unsettling result to
come out of the Natural Sciences since
the Scientific Revolution of the
Renaissance is that even things like
particles can be in conditions where it
simply radically fails to make sense
even to ask where the thing is located
in space what's particularly strange
about this is that of course there are
other circumstances where it does make
sense to ask those questions about where
it's located in space the electron
determinately goes into the box over
here and comes out over there okay but
we can give good arguments from these
experiments that while it's inside it's
not merely that we don't know where it
is it's something much more radical and
much more unsettling than that that the
very act of raising a question about
where it is represents some kind of
misunderstanding of what mode of being
that electron is participating in while
it's going through this device here's a
further fact about electrons if we go if
we do one of these experiments that
described and stop it in the middle rip
the box open okay and go look for the
electron as a matter of fact we always
find that in some determinate position
okay we have equations we have basic
laws of motion the Schrodinger equation
in the case of nonrelativistic quantum
mechanics in the case of relativistic
quantum mechanics the fundamental
equations are the Dirac equation or the
klein-gordon equation anyway we have
these fundamental laws of motion for
things like electrons indeed for all
material things and these laws are very
successful at predicting when these
strange let me back up and say these
conditions in which in which it fails to
make sense to ask whether the electron
is here and here the the in in in a long
distinguished tradition of facing a
mystery that one doesn't understand by
at least making up a name for it a name
has been made up for this condition
people speak of electrons in such
circumstances as being in a
superposition of going along route a and
going along route B and although it's
very difficult for us to get our heads
around what this word means
we we are very adept at treating these
situations mathematically we have very
reliable equations that tell us when and
under what circumstances these super
positions are going to arise and when
they're going to go away and bla bla bla
bla bla good further empirical fact when
we rip open these boxes and look for
these electrons we always find them in
one position or another okay so that
somehow the act of looking at them makes
these super positions go away okay
good on the other hand we could perform
the following exercise take these
fundamental equations that we have
discovered and which we have very good
reason to believe are reliable at
predicting when super positions
going to arise and when they're going to
go away and so on and so forth
use those equations to predict what or
to occur when we rip the box open and
look inside that may sound like a very
difficult calculation to do it involves
this macroscopic human being and his
brain and so on and so forth
actually there's a mathematical trick
for getting this calculation done as
miraculous as that sounds and it's very
easy to show that what these equations
predict ought to occur when we rip this
box of them is that we ourselves go into
a superposition of seeing the electron
on rue de and seeing the electron on
root B okay that is that we ourselves go
into some condition in which not only
does it fail to make sense to ask where
the electron is it fails to make sense
even to ask about our beliefs about
where the electron is okay or it fails
to make sense to ask whether we're in
the brain state corresponding to
believing that the electron is on route
a or on the bridge in the brain state
corresponding to believing that the
electron is on route B good God knows
what the hell that would feel like okay
but the usual way of setting up this
measurement problem is merely to observe
that whatever it is that would feel like
that's not what happens to us when we
rip open these boxes when we rip open
these boxes there is always a perfectly
determinate matter of fact about where
we take the electron to be sometimes we
see it on route a sometimes we see it on
route B it's never the case that
anything else is going on it's never the
case that it looks fuzzy or we get
nauseous or we become disoriented or in
any sense that one can put ones finger
on there fails to be a fact about where
we see the electron good so we have a
flat-out contradiction and this is the
more explicit version of the way the
story about the glass breaks down we
have a flat-out contradiction between on
the one hand the predictions of the
fundamental economic
a nickel equations of motion about what
ought to happen when we rip open these
boxes and and our everyday introspective
experience of what's going on when we
rip open these boxes which is that in
each of those occasions we either see an
electron there or we see an electron
there these two claims flatly contradict
one another of course you know the
empirical the empirical claim is the one
that's true that that's the one that we
see from our observations there's
something wrong with these equations on
the other hand we also know that there's
an enormous and enormous amount that's
right about these equations these
equations are where you know I'm
indescribably vast swathes of 20th
century science and technology come from
these equations get an enormous amount
right on the other hand it couldn't be
more obvious from our everyday
experience of the world and of ourselves
that something is wrong with them
there's a problem about how to put these
two facts together there's a problem
more specifically of how to modify the
theory in such a way that this
contradiction goes away without ruining
the rest of the good predictions of the
theory this problem once again is called
the measurement problem
throughout most of the 20th century what
was widely considered to be the lesson
of quantum mechanics so it was widely
considered to be the upshot the the the
deep upshot of our scientific
investigations of subatomic particles
was precisely that the thought that
science was going to ultimately give us
a picture of the world all the way to
the bottom which we were going to be
able to carry around in our heads okay
which we're going to be which we were
going to be able to understand in the
way we understand billiard balls
colliding with one another or something
like that it's widely been thought to be
the upshot of quantum mechanics that
those expectations of science have now
been exposed as quaint and naive and
old-fashioned and moreover as
presumptuous okay who were we to think
okay you know with these brains evolved
for very different purposes of hunting
and gathering and so on and so forth
that that that that there was going to
be this kind of intelligible mechanical
model of the world that we were going to
be able to get our heads around okay
and indeed the response to this
measurement problem throughout most of
the 20th century was precisely that look
this is where our this is where our
scientific imagination gives out in its
attempt to penetrate the world we have
encountered for the first time ever the
ultimate limits of the capacity of the
scientific project to penetrate into the
foundations of the world we're not going
to get farther than this we should be
thankful enough that we have a good
mechanism for predicting the behaviors
of these particles and so on and so
forth that was very much the consensus
throughout most of the 20th century and
if students were to
raise their hands and say gee how can
you be so sure of this I mean I mean
have people tried to to make these
modifications bla bla bla
those students would be referred to a
number of famous so-called no go
theorems or no hidden variable theorems
the most famous of which for most of the
century was one due to the mathematician
John von Neumann and it wasn't until
rather late in the century that
attention began to be focused on the
fact that these theorems and these
arguments that we couldn't do better
than this were hasty were premature that
the theorems especially the von Neumann
theorem was just a very flawed theorem
the mathematics was completely correct
but the presumptions that he started
with were much too restrictive there was
no reason to be persuaded that those
assumptions were true and since then
mostly over the past 25 years enormous
progress has been made okay
in actually proposing ways to tinker
with these fundamental equations in such
a way as to solve this problem in such a
way as indeed to provide us with
precisely the sort of thoroughly
intelligible mechanical picture of what
was going on that was said for most of
the 20th century to be quaint and
outmoded and and immature and and so on
and so forth so yeah you're right
throughout most of the 20th century the
reaction was the lesson to take from
this is that there are limits to the
capacity of the human scientific
imagination to penetrate the mysteries
of nature and the mature thing to do the
grown-up thing to do is to accept these
limits it isn't until recently that it's
become clear that these pronouncements
were enormous ly premature who knows if
we're going
finish the scientific project or not who
knows if we're ever going to get to the
bottom of it but there is this really
interesting episode in the 20th century
where it was thought that we had and
it's now becoming clearer and clearer
that the announcements of the death of
this project after Mark Twain were were
greatly exaggerated
quantum mechanics is supposed to be a
completely general account of the
behavior of the physical world the way
quantum mechanics emerged historically
was that around the end of the 19th
century the beginning of the 20th
century there were more and more reasons
to be worried that the prevailing
classical physics that is the physics of
Newton and later of Maxwell who
incorporated electromagnetic phenomena
into Newton's theory that that the
Newtonian maxwellian model of the world
that we had was apparently going to be
unable to account for atomic structure
was going to be unable to account for
things as simple as the stability of
matter a famous a famous problem that
that very much worried people just in
the period immediately before quantum
mechanics was emerged was that people
had experimentally seen that the atom
apparently consisted of a of a small
positively charged core with electrons
rotating around it and it's easy to show
from Maxwell's equations that electrons
circling around going in a circular
orbit around a core like that are going
to produce huge amounts of
electromagnetic radiation they're going
to lose all of the energy of their
orbits to this radiation they should
very quickly crash into the nuclei and
matter should cease to exist so there
was a very acute problem about how
matter could be stable at all the more
this and other related problems were
looked into at the beginning of the
century
the more that the less it looked as if
there was any hope at all of an
explanation of these phenomena along the
lines of Newtonian and maxwellian
classical physics it looked like this
was going to call for nothing less than
it than a
global revolution in our fundamental
theories of physics and over a period of
10 years or so centered on Marya between
1920 and 1930 say a new fundamental
theory of the world was developed called
quantum mechanics quantum mechanics then
aspires to be a complete replacement for
Newtonian mechanics it now proposes to
be understood as the fundamental laws of
the evolutions of the physical states of
every kind of physical system but as it
as it surely should have quantum
mechanics was engineered in such a way
as to essentially reproduce the
predictions of classical mechanics for
those systems human sized systems
macroscopic and larger systems for which
Newtonian mechanics was known to do a
good job okay and the way it worked out
was that the predictions of quantum
mechanics differed significantly from
those of Newtonian mechanics only for
for very small kinds of physical systems
subatomic systems so on and so forth
which is exactly where we needed it to
differ so it's important to to separate
how the theory was discovered and what
it was what it was originally developed
for from what it proposes to be once
it's there it was originally developed
to account for a new phenomena that we
had discovered at the subatomic level
okay but it was it would be a serious
misunderstanding to interpreted
therefore as merely a specialized theory
of subatomic objects it's supposed to be
the theory of the entire physical world
but its discovery was prompted by
failures of the previously existing
theory in the subatomic realm
string theory is a version of quantum
mechanics that is quantum mechanics is
is less a completely specific theory
than a than a class of theories theories
that involve this principle of
superposition that we were just talking
about theories whose fundamental
equations of motion have a certain
particular kind of mathematical
structure so on and so forth so one can
enumerate five or six basic principles
of quantum mechanics okay and these
principles allow for a way that rather
wide range of more specific claims of
exactly what elementary systems the
world is made of and and so on so forth
so string theory is is one version of
quantum mechanics one version of a
quantum theory it's a theory whose
fundamental ontological entities aren't
particles but these one-dimensional
objects these strings and and that
fundamental ontology looks promising for
all sorts of reasons especially in
regard to attempt to make a coherent
quantum theory of gravitation and so on
and so forth but in the context of our
discussion here it's one version of a
quantum theory it shares all of the
weird properties that we were just
talking about the measurement problem
the principle of superposition so on and
so forth with every other quantum theory
and these foundational problems
especially the measurement problem come
up in string theory in exactly the same
way as they come up in older versions of
quantum mechanics
we need we need to smack particles
together you know this is this is of
course a one doesn't want to anticipate
what's going to happen and maybe
tomorrow somebody's going to figure out
some much more clever and much cheaper
experimental method of distinguishing
between the string theories and other
quantum theories we have but insofar as
we know at the moment the only way of
getting a handle on whether or not
string theory is true is going to be the
very brute force very expensive project
of building these huge accelerators
they're going to smack particles
together with such intensity that is
that is with energies with energies
reminiscent of the energies that
particles had in the in the very early
milliseconds of the life of the universe
where the predictions of string theory
are going to differ from the predictions
of other interesting quantum theories
that we have on the table so it's going
to be a matter of doing those it's going
to be a matter of doing those
experiments
no even that I mean I mean there may be
the evidence that we would get even from
that as far as I understand the matter
would still be rather indirect although
there are things that could emerge from
those experiments which which would be a
more comfortable fit for certain string
theories than them then for other
theories that we have on the table but
even that evidence is is going to be is
going to be rather indirect you know
what most people say nowadays is look
the best evidence we have for string
theory is that there is a phenomenon of
gravitation and we don't know anyway
besides string theory of making
gravitation compatible with quantum
mechanics
it's been thought to and presumably it
does in in one way or another there have
certainly been episodes in the history
of struggling with the measurement
problem over the past fifty years or so
when distinguished physicists for
example Eugene Wigner Nobel Prize winner
enormous Lee distinguished theoretical
physicist of the first half a middle of
the of the 20th century became convinced
around the middle of the century that
that consciousness was going to be an
absolutely essential and in illimitable
ingredient of any possible solution to
the measurement problem that we were
talking about before you remember that
the problem was that when we ripped this
box open we see an electron either here
or there but the fundamental quantum
mechanical equations of motion if you
apply them as well to our brains would
seem to predict the opposite okay that
we don't distinctly see an electron here
or there rather our brains end up in a
superposition of the state associated
with seeing it here and the state
associated with seeing it there that is
our brains end up end up in some
condition where it fails even to make
sense where we believe the electrons
would be okay
Vigna took a look at this situation and
said well
so apparently what's going on here is
that our brain or at the very least our
mind seems to be evolving in a way that
directly violates these fundamental
equations of motion and and vig neurs
approach to this was instead of seeing
this as bad news okay to see it as the
news we've been waiting for you know
since the beginning of science here is
finally a proof that the mind of the
observer is not a physical object and is
not tied to physical objects in the way
that rocks are or tables or chairs or so
on and so forth
that is the reason the reason that the
fundamental equations apply to our
brains end up making the wrong
predictions so said Vigna was because
our brains have this special additional
feature of being associated with
consciousness okay and this this had the
sort of cute effect of turning the
traditional mind-body problem on its
head traditionally the worry has been
that the that the picture of the world
that's emerging from physics is hostile
to mind that there's no place for mind
in it okay that we can analyze
everything in terms of the physics of
our brains why I'm saying this why I do
everything I do so on and so forth its
hostile to mind it's hostile to all of
these things that we associate with mind
like freedom of will so on and so forth
Bigler thought he had an argument that
as a matter of fact in quantum mechanics
precisely the opposite turns out to be
true
not only is physics not hostile to the
idea that there is a distinct
non-physical mental thing intervening in
the physical world not only is it not
hostile to that it absolutely needs that
in order to make the right predictions
it absolutely needs this mind to come in
and violate the equations of motion in
order to make this electron end up in
one determinate place or another which
is what we observe at doing so vikner
thought first of all he had for the
first time a clean mathematical
definition of the dista of the
difference between a physical entity and
a mental entity a physical entity is by
definition an entity that obeys these
equations of motion a mental entity is
the kind of entity that is capable of
causing violations of those equations of
motion good
this sounds cute for about 10 min
but it quickly became embarrassing I
remember myself as a young graduate
student being at conferences where
vinner would stand up and speculate that
that that although dogs could likely
cause violations of the equations of
motion mice probably couldn't and and it
just became silly and embarrassing and
one didn't know where he was coming up
with this and one was going to be forced
in order to write down the fundamental
physical laws in a clean way to make
these distinctions between conscious and
not conscious where is what seems much
more plausible to everybody is that
there's some continuum going from from
conscious to not conscious rather than
some clean cut off point and it was just
a mess
so this was a view that was that was
entertained seriously for about a
fifteen year period from the mid from
the early 50s maybe to the late 60s and
hasn't been taken particularly seriously
by physicists since then on the other
hand the existence of this view in this
earlier historical period has been a
goldmine for New Age enthusiasms about
quantum mechanics
ever since then
I mean very broadly speaking look there
are there are you know one can contrast
two very different ways of coming at the
world what can one can come at the world
determined in advance that what one is
going to find at the bottom of it is
some reassuring flattering more or less
comfortable image of oneself or one can
come at the world in a genuinely more
open way to see what the world has to
teach you and to determine as much as
one can to keep one's eyes open whether
one finds what one expected to find in
advance
or not there are human limitations no
doubt to the capacity to do that but
there are some people who are more
resolute about doing that than others
and it seems to me what unifies all the
new-age approaches to various kinds of
scientific discoveries is that the
curiosity turns out very quickly not to
be authentic okay what one was after it
quickly emerges from the beginning was
reassurance that all sorts of things one
already thought about the world and
about oneself before the investigation
even began are going to be confirmed and
if they're not confirmed you're gonna
lie about what the science says in order
to make it appear that they were
confirmed this is very much the opposite
of the scientific spirit that want
admirers and hopes to hopes to emulate
as much as one can which involves a
profoundly more authentic and profound
more courageous kind of curiosity than
that the picture that science presents
us with of ourselves it seems to me for
all that anybody might want to say about
it I don't know how to put this it seems
to me that the picture that we're
presented with of ourselves by science
is a picture if you really stay in it if
you really take it in connected with
some kind of bottomless terror okay
where where the science presents us with
a picture of ourselves as machines okay
as you know as billiard balls knocking
into one another at the very bottom of
things and that's why we do what we do
and that's why the world is the way it
is it seems to me that that if one
really opens oneself to what science has
to tell you about yourself the the
category of sort of aesthetic reaction
that it falls into is something like the
uncanny okay especially in the way that
term is used in psychoanalysis where
it's associated with with with
apparently animate objects that turn out
to be inanimate or the other way around
there's something really there's
something really indescribably strange
about the picture that we're presented
with of ourselves by especially by
fundamental physics and it's a picture
that we just don't know how to fully
take in and I think it's very very very
disturbing and I think that's as exactly
the opposite as it could be of what
typically is said to come out of science
from new age understandings of it
in a number of ways first of all you
might say that the that the sort of
gesture with which physics gets underway
in the first place
is a gesture that lots of philosophers
in the continental tradition have come
to call the spatialization of time that
is the way time if it appears in physics
is as another component a fourth
component of the address of an event
okay you you want to say you know you
want to say what what there is to say
about events is where they were located
and how they were distributed blah blah
blah in the in the X dimension in the Y
dimension in the Z dimension and in the
T dimension and what physics aspires to
tell us and all physics aspires to tell
us when you get right down to it is how
matter and energy gets distributed over
over this fourth dimension over this
four dimensional block of X Y Z and T
okay you tell me where all the particles
are in X Y Z and T I'll tell you the
history of the world okay
that's supposed to be according to the
model we've been dealing with in physics
from the word go all there is to say
about the world from the word go then
something is being done with time that
that does enormous violence to our
pre-scientific intuitions about time pre
scientifically it seems like time is as
different from space as you could
possibly imagine and and the way
discussions of this often go is that
people will immediately say well I you
know time moves or flows space doesn't
move or flow I can move around it will
in space I can't move
it will in time all these kinds of
things time seems just as different as
it could be from space and indeed
there's a tradition in continental
philosophy in European philosophy you
find this in people like Heidegger or
Deleuze or people like that that it is
the fundamental mistake of physics this
specialist specialization of time it's
from that moment on that physics had
already doomed itself to not being able
to say anything deep or interesting
about what time was physics on the other
hand has this interesting retort that it
can apparently explain why you say all
these things you say about how time is
different from space on a model in which
time is just another parameter in the
address in the address of an event so so
there is this very interesting
conversation that there is this very
interesting dialogue where on the one
hand it looks like physics has made from
the word go a profound error about what
time is physics on the other hand is is
it has been up to now always in a
position to come back and say you want
me to explain to you based on physics
why you say time passes even though that
doesn't actually mean anything and why
you're talking the way you do about our
capacity to move around in space but not
in time so on and so forth I can do all
that it's like it's very much like when
Newtonian mechanics was first proposed
and it was widely objected that if the
earth was indeed moving through space at
the enormous velocities that it's
predicted to be by Newtonian mechanics
everybody would fall off okay and the
beauty of Newtonian mechanics was to be
able to say not merely that I have an
explanation of why we don't fall off but
that the very same theory that predicts
that the earth is going to be moving so
fast is also going to predict
that we wouldn't fall off indeed it's
also going to predict that we would
think it isn't moving even though it is
one wants to play this game in in the
with the scientific conception of time
as well maybe I should go a bit further
specifically there is within physics the
following problem that's been sitting
around for about a hundred years now at
the foundations of physics which goes
like this imagine watching a film of two
billiard balls collide so in the first
frame you just see a billiard ball
sitting at the center of the frame then
another billiard ball comes in hits the
one that's at rest the one that was
moving is now at rest and the one that
was previously at rest goes off and
exits the frame on the other side
imagine that you were shown this film in
Reverse so what you're going to see is
the second billiard ball coming in here
hitting the first one which was has now
been at rest up until this point in the
reversed movie and now the first one
goes out and leaves the frame on the
other side note that the set of events
depicted by the movie being shown in
Reverse is just as much in accord with
everything we believe about the laws
governing collisions between billiard
balls as is the movie being shown in the
correct direction that is if you were
shown a movie like this and asked to
guess just based on your familiarity
with the laws of physics just based on
your family from the arity with how
billiard balls behave when they collide
if you were shown a film like this and
asked to guess whether you're whether it
was being shown forward or in reverse
you wouldn't be able to tell physicists
express this by saying that the laws
governing collisions between billiard
balls are symmetric under time reversal
okay and what that means
concretely is a law is said to be
symmetric under time reversal if it's
the case that for any process which is
in accord with that law that the same
process going in Reverse that is the
same process as it would appear in the
in a film going backwards is also an
accord with that law so we say that the
laws governing collisions between pairs
of billiard balls are time reversal
symmetric good
it's an astonishing thing that all of
the serious candidates that anybody has
entertained for fundamental laws of
physics from Newton onward so by this I
mean Newton's laws I mean Maxwell's
equations I mean the Schrodinger
equation I mean general relativity I
mean string theory everything it's an
astonishing fact about all of these
theories even though they differ wildly
from one another in all kinds of other
respects and even though they straddle
different sides of enormous scientific
revolutions
it's an astonishing fact about every
single one of these theories that all of
them are perfectly symmetric under time
reversal every single one of them has
the feature that for any process which
is an accord with those laws the process
going in reverse is in accord with those
laws as well what this pose is a problem
and once again just as with the
measurement problem the structure of
this problem is a clash between the the
laws of physics that we have developed
by carefully observing the behaviors of
microscopic systems and our everyday
macroscopic experience of the world okay
what's the problem the problem is that
if we get more sophisticated than
collisions between billiard balls okay
if we imagine a film of someone walking
down the street or or of a piece of
paper being consumed by fire or or a
time lapse film of somebody growing old
or something like that we can damn well
tell
very easily whether we are being shown
the film forward or in Reverse
okay now that is that is very directly
at odds with what we have what we take
ourselves to have very good reasons for
believing about the structure or the
fundamental physical laws which are
supposed to govern all of these
processes namely that those laws are
perfectly symmetric under time reversal
okay to put it slightly differently on
the level of fundamental physical law
there doesn't seem to be any distinction
whatsoever between past and future okay
moving from the present into the future
ought to look statistically speaking
just like moving from the present into
the past if those laws are true on the
other hand it's probably not exact an
exaggeration to say that the most basic
primordial unavoidable feature of our
everyday experience of being in the
world
is that there is all the difference in
the world between the past in the future
in our everyday experience of the world
there is an extremely vivid and
pronounced temporal direction okay on
the level of the fundamental laws that
temporal direction apparently completely
vanishes okay once again there's a
question and like I say this question
has a similar structure to the question
of the measurement problem in that it's
a clash between our fundamental
equations of motion and our everyday
experience macroscopic experience of
being in the world there's a question
with time about how to put these two
things together once again it appears as
if although the theory does an extremely
good job of predicting the motions of
elementary particles and so on and so
forth there's got to be something wrong
with it okay because we have although we
have very good clear quantitative
experience in the laboratory which bears
out these
time-reversal symmetric laws at some
point there's got to be something wrong
with them because the world that we live
in is manifestly not even close to being
time-reversal symmetric and once again
there are proposals on the table for how
to fiddle around with the theory adding
a new law governing initial conditions
for example or there are all kinds of
proposals about how to deal with this
but this has been this is a very
fundamental challenge although we've got
laws that are doing a fantastic job on
the micro level there's some way in
which these laws manifestly get things
wrong on the macro level and we need to
figure out what to do about that